sur le fondement de l'article de 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution
s'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement se devait être la réforme
phare du second quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron la réforme des retraites c'est
une réforme essentielle si on veut
pouvoir continuer à préserver notre
modèle social alors même qu'on peut plus
monter les impôts donc il n'y a qu'un
moyen de faire si on est lucide comme
nous vivons plus longtemps c'est de
travailler plus longtemps elle a
déclenché la colère de la rue on n'est
pas en train d'essayer de bloquer le
pays ou de mettre le bordel on est en
train d'expliquer que les 64 ans pour
nombre de travailleurs c'est pas
possible et enflammé l'Assemblée
nationale
vous êtes un imposteur et un assassin
les engagements présidentiels
entre l'obstruction de la gauche les
haters
les approximations du gouvernement
retour sur un impossible débat au Palais
Bourbon
[Musique]
moins de 10 jours après l'annonce
officielle de la réforme des retraites
les Français sont dans la rue à Paris
comme en province c'est du jamais vu
depuis des décennies les 8 principaux
syndicats du pays appellent ensemble à
manifester les députés de la nupesse
l'Alliance de gauche sont dans le
cortège et charpent bandoulière et
basket au pied et si
vous pouvez légendaire de Louis Boyard
parce que il a mis sur Twitter la tête
de ses baskets pour appeler à manifester
moi j'ai fait moins de mois de base que
lui mais je l'ai fait avec mes basques
avec mes bottes on a eu la même idée
donc en fait c'est pas une histoire de
courage c'est une histoire d'habitude en
fait ça
les insoumis les socialistes les
communistes les écologistes
la gauche affiche son unité derrière les
syndicats
là c'est une bataille avant l'ouverture
du débat l'Assemblée nationale et je
pense que les deux doivent se répondre
c'est-à-dire que c'est le nombre de dans
la rue qui va permettre de mettre la
pression sur le gouvernement et nous à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat nous serons en
écho à ce qui se passe dans la rue
laupède veut mobiliser vite pour contrer
le gouvernement qui a lancé le compte à
rebours il a choisi une loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
lui permet de circonscrire la durée des
débats à 50 jours au Parlement selon le
désormais célèbre article 47 ans de la
Constitution bien sûr que le
gouvernement veut passer en force et il
a inventé ce 47,1 qui est une sorte de
49,3 low cost c'est c'est une manière
effectivement de d'aller plus vite en
espérant que il peut couper l'herbe sous
le pied de la mobilisation moi j'ai en
tête 2006 le CPU il avait été voté la
mobilisation a continué et on a réussi à
faire que le gouvernement retire son
projet de loi l'espoir est permis cette
première mobilisation est un immense
succès il y avait entre 1 et 2 millions
de personnes dans la rue
même si elle s'oppose à la réforme lors
la Valette ne participe pas aux
manifestations ce n'est pas dans l'ADN
de son parti le rassemblement national à
une semaine de l'arrivée du projet de
loi à l'Assemblée la députée du Var et
ses collègues préfèrent fourbirent leurs
armes parlementaires il ne déposeront
que très peu d'amendements
l'idée donc l'idée c'est de balayer
chaque article de voir ce qu'on fait
comme amendement
qu'on garde pour la séance est-ce qu'il
y a des moments qu'on utilise dès la
commission mais ce qu'il faut que c'est
quand même qu'on puisse au-delà du
dénoncer cette réforme par les
propositions de marine dans le message
je pense qu'il est clair c'est un
message qu'on a défendu déjà toute
l'année dernière pendant la campagne
présidentielle c'était très clair et
c'est aussi la simplicité j'allais dire
de notre message c'est si vous avez
commencé à travailler entre 17 et 20 ans
vous pouvez partir à la retraite à 60
ans avec 40 à nuts pleines et après
c'est progressif jusqu'à 62 ans
s'il veut faire adopter sa réforme
Emmanuel Macron a clairement besoin
d'allier puisqu'il n'a pas de majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale alors
depuis des semaines le gouvernement
négocie avec la droite qui défend depuis
longtemps un report de l'âge de la
retraite les républicains ont en main le
destin du projet de loi pour cette
nouvelle année plein de choses pour vous
faire le meilleur le député Stéphane
Viry est l'un des chefs de file de son
groupe dans ce dossier dans son fief des
Vosges il a rendez-vous avec ses
militants locaux s'installe à qui il
résume le dilemme des républicains
si on est pour
le RN va nous taper dessus à bras
raccourci on est la majorité on est
macroniste il y a donc plus que le RN
qui représente l'opposition et une
alternance
si on est contre
alors qu'il y a réellement des mesures
qui vont dans la finalité de ce que
pense la droite travailler longtemps
consolider le système de retraite si on
est contre ceux qui pensent que la
droite doit être responsable ils vont
nous dire vraiment vous êtes contre tout
vous servez à rien donc quoi qu'il
arrive le temps politique de ce début
d'année pour les républicains il est
compliqué
les républicains hésitent la gauche est
vend debout le rassemblement national
aussi la rue est mobilisée le dossier
des retraites s'annonce explosif à
l'Assemblée la députée Renaissance
Stéphanie riste à la lourde tâche d'être
rapporteur de ce projet de loi
[Musique]
notre objectif est d'examiner le texte
d'arriver à faire que cet examen du
texte soit possible il y a deux façons
pour que ce soit possible que ça se
passe correctement dans les débats de
façon très respectueuse d'un côté de
l'autre donc voilà et l'autre c'est
aussi de voir si on a une majorité ou
pas sur ce texte enfin moi je suis
plutôt optimiste à ce jour en même temps
consciente que les mouvements sociaux
qui existent sont à prendre en compte
dans le fait que certains députés
pourraient changer d'avis à 10 jours du
débat dans l'hémicycle la députée a
rendez-vous avec Franck ryester le
ministre chargé des Relations avec le
Parlement
il s'inquiète du grand nombre
d'amendements qui pourraient bloquer
l'examen du texte n'a plus de chimie mes
administrateurs me disent qu'on arrivait
à 7005 malgré tout d'habitude tu es à
on aura du mal à aller jusqu'au bout là
on voit qu'avec le nombre d'un moment il
y aura forcément des amendements qui
sont là pour faire perdre du temps et
donc une forme d'obstruction le
gouvernement de le souvenir cuisant de
la précédente tentative de réforme des
retraites la France insoumise va-t-elle
comme en 2019 emboliser l'assemblée avec
un déluge d'amendement avec cette année
4 fois plus de députés et le renfort de
ses alliés de la nupestres
dès la semaine prochaine ça on va en
parler après une stratégie qui sera
définie loin des caméras une stratégie
tout aussi offensive qu'en 2019 mais
plus imprévisible pour tenter de
maîtriser le temps parlementaire
oui il y aura des milliers d'amendements
ça c'est sûr qui seront sur le fond à
chaque fois et qui peuvent soit être
maintenues jusqu'au bout soit être
retiré et donc on va pouvoir ajuster en
réalité notre stratégie au fur et à
mesure avec un objectif de pas faciliter
la tâche du gouvernement mais le combat
pied à pied en écho avec la mobilisation
et un deuxième objectif qui est
absolument d'avoir le débat sur
l'article 7 l'article 7 qui repousse
l'âge légal et l'essence de la réforme
dans la rue la pression s'accentue pour
dire non au 64 ans tout est prêt pour un
combat parlementaire intense
après l'articlement il y a beaucoup de
gens qui n'y arrivent
favorable l'opposition à déposer plus de
20 000 amendements alors le camp
présidentiel c'est déjà que le projet de
loi ne pourra pas être examiné dans son
intégralité
mais en même temps on va pas s'ennuyer
on va regarder le côté positif
c'est beaucoup d'amendements pour
arriver à cette première partie
peut-être que d'un seul coup ils seront
retirés donc ça nécessite de d'être bien
en cohésion et de bien être présent
parce que bien sûr il retireront pas
leurs amendement au moment où on sera
tous là
à quelques minutes du début des
hostilités les 150 députés de gauche
font une démonstration de force
le gouvernement peut faire toutes les
circonvolutions qu'il veut la vérité que
chacun et chacune aura bien comprises
c'est qu'il n'y a pas plus injuste pour
les carrières péniées pour les carrières
longues pour tous celles et tous ceux
qu'on a applaudis à 20h que la réforme
qui a proposé vous avez compris nous à
l'unisson c'est non les députés du
rassemblement national eux ne sont que
88 mais ils sont en compétition avec la
nupes pour s'afficher comme les
principaux opposants à Emmanuel Macron
Marine Le Pen a donc décidé de déposer
une motion pour pousser le gouvernement
à organiser un référendum ce sujet des
retraites représente un réel choix de
société il n'est donc pas aberrant qu'il
soit tranché par référendum
nature optimiste j'espère encore qu'une
majorité de députés va voter cette
motion a commencé par ce de la nupesse
qui devrait faire leur les paroles de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je cite je mets au
défi les autres parties qui se disent de
position d'adopter la motion
référendaire
Marine Le Pen met la nuesse au pied du
mur mais elle sait bien que la gauche ne
votera jamais avec le rassemblement
national et que sa demande de référendum
ne sera qu'un coup d'épée dans l'eau
[Musique]
bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte dès
le début le ton est donné
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du
saint au ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier dufe ministre du Travail du plan
d'emploi et de l'insertion s'il vous
plaît
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
nous y sommes
nous y sommes vous laissez parler le
ministre merci madame la Présidente je
disais madame la Présidente
s'il vous plaît vous n'avez pas attrapé
les pupitres la parole est au
gouvernement madame la Présidente le
ministre ne parvient pas à commencer son
discours
[Applaudissements]
ah non ah non merci madame la Présidente
est-ce que vous croyez que nous allons
passer 15 jours comme cela dans les
musiques oui monsieur le ministre madame
la Présidente donc Mesdames et Messieurs
les Députés nous y sommes et quand bien
même vous ne le voudrez pas nous y
sommes des engagements présidentiels
de l'Assemblée nationale
il faudra presque une heure à Olivier du
soft pour entamer son propos
je disais il y a un instant
l'examen du projet de loi s'annonce
difficile pour le gouvernement mais il
est prêt au bras de fer n'ayons pas peur
de le dire en matière de
retraite ou la faillite c'est ça la
réalité de notre système aujourd'hui
dès le lendemain les Français sont à
nouveau dans la rue après cette première
journée chaotique de discussion les
syndicats mettent désormais la pression
sur le gouvernement et sur l'Assemblée
nationale quand j'entends à la fois le
gouvernement nous dire que c'est soit
cette réforme là soit la faillite on
sait que c'est complètement fou parce
qu'il y a d'autres solutions
l'obstruction pour faire de
l'obstruction ça ne sert à rien donc
aujourd'hui on voit que le débat
parlementaire n'est pas à la hauteur et
donc c'est où est-ce que ça bloque c'est
pas chez nous on n'est pas en train
d'essayer de bloquer le pays ou de
mettre le bordel on est en train
d'expliquer que les 64 ans pour nombre
de travailleurs c'est pas possible il
faut que le gouvernement il faut que le
Parlement entendrez
dans le cortège parisien de cette
troisième manifestation il y a aussi les
insoumis et surtout le premier d'entre
eux même s'il n'est plus député Jean-Luc
Mélenchon surveille de près ce qui se
passe à l'Assemblée et veut toujours
donner le ton
bonjour les week-ends
au Parlement on ne se tait pas c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire le débat
n'avance que très lentement pour le
groupe du Rassemblement national ce
monsieur Thomas ménager au total il y a
plus de 20 000 amendements sur le projet
de loi dont 18 000 déposés par la
nupesse
retirez vos amendements ne servez pas la
soupe au gouvernement vous les aider ils
sont très heureux de ne pas parler du
fond de passer des heures et des heures
sur ce qui l'intéresse pas les français
ce qui intéresse les Français c'est la
pénibilité au bout de quatre jours seul
l'article premier mettant fin au régime
spéciaux a été adopté
mais cette lenteur ne fait-elle pas les
affaires du camp présidentiel qui n'est
pas sûr d'avoir une majorité
non mais moi en tant que rapporteur j'ai
très envie qu'on puisse examiner
l'ensemble des articles qu'on puisse
débattre améliorer le texte et c'est ça
sert à quoi d'autre en étant député que
de pouvoir améliorer les textes donc si
on est là juste pour des tribunes qui
peuvent se faire ailleurs que dans
l'hémicycle faisons les ailleurs mais
dans l'hémicycle travaillons à l'examen
du texte
la semaine va se terminer comme elle a
commencé sous haute tension c'est un
tweet qui crée l’étincelle celui du
député insoumi thomasport sur cette
photo il pose avec au pied un ballon à
l'effigie du ministre Olivier du soft
alors quand le député veut prendre la
parole l’hémicycle s'embrassent
madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres
calmez-vous collègues il y a pas de
ballons ici
nous exposez souris aux lèvres avec
votre écharpe tricolore
foulant des pieds écrasant de vos pieds
la tête d'un ministre de la République
c'est un ni plus ni moi un appel au
meurtre ni plus ni moi un appel au
meurtre
je crois que l'hémicycle vous demande
des excuses
[Applaudissements]
le jour où vont entier c'était très fort
qui va sacrifier des milliers
la séance est interrompue
après deux heures de réunion des
instances de la santé la sanction tombe
Thomas porte est exclu pour 15 jours du
Palais Bourbon la première semaine de
débat se termine alors qu'un seul des 20
articles du projet de loi a été voté
[Musique]
les esclandre et la lenteur des
discussions attise la colère de
l'intersyndical et d'une partie de
l'opinion publique
les syndicats pressent les députés
tu crois que ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale ne sert pas
mais je suis pas le seul à le penser ne
sert pas ce qu'on est en train de faire
dans la rue bien sûr moi c'est pour ça
que je pose comme ambition et Philippe
Martinez aussi et d'autres aussi que à
minimal article 7 soit en débat à
l'Assemblée nationale cette semaine on
souhaite que cet article soit mis en
débat c'est de ça dont il s'agit dans la
rue pour des millions de personnes et
c'est pas en débat
la dernière semaine de débat démarre les
députés parviendront-ils à discuter de
ce fameux article 7 celui qui reporte
l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans les débats
de fonds vont-ils enfin pouvoir
commencer
[Musique]
monsieur du soft puisque vous avez voulu
parler des morts du travail je vous
donne les chiffres qu'entre 2017 et 2019
c'est 33% d'accidents du travail causant
la mort en plus et vous avez la
responsabilité de ses choix politiques
vous êtes un imposteur et un assassin
les propos du député insoumis provoquent
un tollé
même les alliés de la nupesse ceux des
solidarisent l'Alliance de gauche se
craquelle
tenir de telles propos est absolument
inacceptable nous sommes ici nous sommes
ici pour nous combattre
mais jamais je dis bien jamais nos
débats nos arguments ne doivent dériver
avec des insultes qui sont portés contre
des marques de cette assemblée et contre
des marques du gouvernement
j'ai eu il y a quelques instants à ce
micro des mots que l'émotion et
l'emportement
m'ont fait mal choisir et qui sont
déplacés je souhaite évidemment les
retirer et adresser des excuses
publiques au ministre
l'incident est clos le débat reprend sur
l'article 2
mesdames
veut démontrer son unité et donner des
gages au syndicats le soir même en coeur
les quatre groupes de gauche retirent
une partie de leurs amendements nous
avons travaillé ensemble pour pouvoir
retirer un millier d'amendements ce soir
qui nous permettra de passer à la suite
on admettre du calendrier on le trouve
ce soir en choisissant d'accélérer
il y a désormais l'espoir que la
discussion avance mais elle s'avère de
plus en plus compliquée pour l'exécutif
qui subit un gros revers
le scrutin et clos les députés rotoquent
l'article 2 qui crée en index au
Seigneur pour 203 contre 256 l'Assemblée
nationale n'a pas adopté c'est un coup
dur pour le gouvernement cela confirme
qu'il n'a pas pour le moment de majorité
pour faire voter sa réforme alors pour
s'assurer du soutien ferme des
républicains la première ministre fait
des concessions sur les carrières
longues pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt sauf que le gouvernement
a bien du mal à expliquer les nouvelles
mesures
je pense très clairement ces propos
monsieur le ministre
qui concerne les demandes de précision
qui ont été faites
j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises le
dispositif carrière longue se
caractérise par des conditions
cumulatives c'est le cas depuis 2003 ni
revenons pas j'ai dit que dans le cadre
du dispositif des carrières longues
ignorait aucune exigence du durée
d'affiliation au régime supérieur à 43
ans quand nous serons à une durée
d'affiliation régime de 43 ans d'où
l'expression monter en charge
bonsoir à tous
personne n'a rien compris et ça commence
à devenir absolument insupportable
gouvernement nous a déjà fait une
annonce à moitié il y a quelques jours
qui est devenu absolument
incompréhensible au fur et à mesure des
explications j'ai reposé une question
très simple à Olivier du socle en lui
demandant si quelqu'un qui avait
commencé à 14 ans à 16 ans ou à 18 ans
au jour de son anniversaire partirait
bien avec 43 annuités ou 44 nuts et le
ministre s'obstine à ne pas répondre à
cette question c'est tout à fait
insupportable on ne tirera rien de ces
débats
sur les revalorisations des petites
retraites ce n'est pas plus clair est-ce
que les 1200 euros concerneront un
million 800 000 retraités 40 000
12000 je désespère
élément d'avoir une réponse au même
question qui nous taraude et nous
languissons pour avoir votre réponse
monsieur le ministre du centre
combien s'il vous plaît combien de
personnes qui partent à la retraite ou
qui sont déjà à la retraite Véro leur
rémunération montée jusqu'à 1200 euros
leur pension les débats de fonds
viennent enfin de commencer au bout de 8
jours de discussion pour accélérer
vraiment les écologistes les communistes
les socialistes enlèvent tous leurs
amendements avant l'article 7 celui sur
les 64 ans nous avons décidé de retirer
tous les amendements que nous avions
déposé jusqu'à l'article 7 puisque nous
avons entendu nous avons compris qu'un
certain nombre
de femmes et d'hommes de force souhaité
que nous puissions arriver à cette
discussion de l'article 7 mais les
insoumis aux signes et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dans un tweet révèle la
véritable stratégie de la France
insoumise ne pas aller à l'article 7
incompréhensible retrait des amendements
du Parti communiste pourquoi se
précipiter à l'article 7 hâte de se
faire battre ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire on sait qu'on est minoritaire on
sait qu'on a pas de majorité pour mettre
en échec le gouvernement et donc il faut
faire traîner les débats c'est ça que
vous dites c'est l'aveu de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
et regardez ce qui se passe dans
l'hémicycle les socialistes ils sont
partis il reste trois écologistes les
communistes y restent trois personnes et
à plus que vous la France insoumise
parce que les autres ne partagent pas
votre obstruction le temps de débat
imparti et bientôt écoulé le dernier
jour ne permet pas d'avancer plus les
députés ont à peine entamé l'étude de
l'article 3
[Musique]
dans moins de 10 minutes ce débat sur la
réforme des retraites va malheureusement
se terminer dans notre dans notre
hémicycle et on compte sur le Sénat pour
faire un travail que nous n'avons
malheureusement pas pu faire ici à cause
de député de la France insoumise je dois
vous dire que je suis je suis concerné
Tracy le Parlement ne pourra pas il
reste 6 minutes délibéré sur cette loi
parce que vous avez choisi un calendrier
parlementaire contre un je vous remercie
au 12 coups de minuit tout s'arrête
11.000 amendements et 18 articles non
pas été examinés
c'est donc dans le respect de la
Constitution que nos débats doivent
désormais prendre soin
les députés insoumis en tonnes le chant
des gilets jaunes
ambiance surréaliste dans les travers
mesdames et messieurs les députés
vous 15 jours vous sortez mais vous
m'avez insulté personne n'a craqué
personne n'a craqué et nous sommes là
devant vous pour la réforme
[Applaudissements]
la réforme par au Sénat alors que les
députés n'auront jamais discuté de
l'article 7 qui impose la retraite à 64
ans
[Applaudissements]
au Palais du Luxembourg les débats sont
longs mais plus sereins qu'à l'Assemblée
les sénateurs en majorité de droite vote
très largement pour la réforme des
retraites
retour au Palais Bourbon l'Assemblée
doit valider l'ultime version du projet
de loi fruit d'un compromis entre 7
députés sept sénateurs mais la première
ministre dispose celle d'une majorité
pour le voter toute la matinée le
gouvernement fait et refait ses calculs
et le compte n'y est pas un quart
d'heure avant le début de la séance il
tronche en faveur de 49,3 avec 8 minutes
de retard Elisabeth borne arrive à
l'Assemblée
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
dans un hémicycle bondé cette fois ce
n'est pas le chant des gilets jaunes
mais la Marseillaise que les insoumis
font retentir pour couvrir la voie de la
première ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Elisabeth borne dégaine le 49-3 et règle
ses comptes avec la nupesse le
rassemblement national et les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
faire oublier à certains les positions
qu'il défendaient quelques mois plus tôt
avec leur famille politique
cet après-midi je n'ai pas envie de
revenir non plus sur le comportement de
ceux qui ont tout fait pour bloquer le
débat et ce sont contentés de multiplier
les insultes les excès et les attaques
[Applaudissements]
enfin cet après-midi je n'ai pas envie
de revenir sur le mutisme de ceux à
l'extrême droite de cette émission qui
sont
de l'ombre tout au long des débats qui
ont préféré se taire profitant en
silence des outrances des uns et des
revirements des autres
aussi sur le fondement de l'article de
49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement
aucune motion censure n'ayant été votée
la réforme des retraites est
définitivement adoptée après 50 jours de
bras de fer et 1/49.3 la victoire à un
goût amer pour le gouvernement
[Musique]